I have a lot of old liberal friends who
are like what happened to you you know
and I'll sit down and I'll explain to
them what happened to me and they'll go
oh yeah I kind of feel some of that too
even though I'm more you know I'm wedded
to my Democrat Party or whatever uh you
know we have those conversations we have
them in a friendly way an intense way
somewhat sometimes what a friendly way
but the other thing is is that there is
now going through the left the Democrat
the central left
they're quietly appalled they're quietly
appalled by some of this gender stuff
they're quietly appalled by what's
happening in schools they understand
that this uh shutdown over covid was a
big mistake uh and and really hurt them
they have kids they see their kids being
hurt and they'll say it but they're
afraid and that's what we have to get
past that's why the daily wire you
anybody who's willing to bring on
alternative voices and who's willing to
take the heat is so important because
the people who don't have our platforms
the people who aren't protected as we
are by the First Amendment and can be
fired by HR for not agreeing you know
with their stupid uh policies those are
the people who are afraid we need to
bring them out into the open we need to
let them know that they shouldn't be
afraid we need to fight the powers that
make them afraid and then I think we'll
be able to talk again
so do you think that this moment that we
find ourselves in between the big Tech
craziness and now just all the exposing
of all of the political nonsense uh that
this is sort of inevitable that that
maybe 20 years of the internet was going
to have to get us to a place like this
so that enough of us could have that
Awakening and then get to the other side
of it that it was going to happen no
matter what that's exactly what I think
and I think that like so much is ending
right now I said this when Donald Trump
was elected this is not the beginning of
something it's the end of something that
will lead to the beginning of something
you know it's the end of the post World
War II era it's the end of the Reagan
Era it's the end of the baby boom Epoch
the Baby Boomers are all going to die
I'm just hoping they won't take me with
them when they go you know and and it is
the invention of this brand new thing I
mean when you think about the invention
of the printing press and then you have
the Reformation of the 30 Years War you
have The Counter Reformation you have
the Inquisition you have all this
violence coming about simply because
suddenly someone can read the Bible and
say you know what I don't think the pope
is right about this you know some clown
in Germany can read the Bible and say
you know actually this doesn't actually
sound like what the pope is saying
that's that's how things fall apart and
that's what's happened here essentially
uh what Colbert's called the pleurisy
the you know this chattering classes uh
have suddenly had their Monopoly of
information taken away from them and so
the counter-reformation is basically the
Inquisition that's going on is as you're
thrown off Twitter you're throwing off
Facebook Google's only going to show you
climate change information that agrees
with what the elites want you to think
didn't work in the Inquisition didn't
work in the counter it's not going to
work now eventually this is the
democratization of information we're
going to learn how to handle it we're
going to learn how to sort
misinformation from information
basically if it's coming from the
government it's misinformation and then
everything else is open the question but
but you know we'll learn to sort it and
we'll stop them from censoring us and I
think ultimately yeah that'll smooth out
let me ask you one someone on the
personal side of how we both go about
doing the political thing relative to
what you're talking about it's getting
harder and harder to find people on the
other side that are that are willing to
have these conversations I would say
it's almost impossible at this point
um are you able to find anybody to talk
to to take the Counterpoint and do it
without you know murdering each other
uh two two in two ways I'm able to do
this first of all older people can still
do it I still have discussions with
older people where you know because I I
have a lot of old liberal friends who
are like what happened to you you know
and I'll sit down and I'll explain to
them what happened to me and they'll go
oh yeah I kind of feel some of that too
even though I'm more you know I'm wedded
to my Democrat Party or whatever uh you
know we have those conversations we have
them in a friendly way an intense way
someone sometimes what a friendly way
but the other thing is is that there is
now going through the left the Democrat
the central left
they're quietly appalled they're quietly
appalled by some of this gender stuff
they're quietly appalled by what's
happening in schools they understand
that this uh shutdown over covid was a
big mistake uh and and really hurt them
they have kids they see their kids being
hurt and they'll say it but they're
afraid and that's what we have to get
past that's why the daily wire you
anybody who's willing to bring on
alternative voices and who's willing to
take the heat is so important because
the people who don't have our platforms
the people who aren't protected as we
are by the First Amendment and can be
fired by HR for not agreeing you know
with their stupid uh policies those are
the people who are afraid we need to
bring them out into the open we need to
let them know that they shouldn't be
afraid we need to fight the powers uh
that make them afraid and then I think
we'll be able to talk again do you think
that that fear thing is a uh is maybe
connected to a spirituality uh deficit
within liberals let's say I mean you you
have an interesting uh spiritual journey
if you were born Jewish you're Christian
but that liberals who tend to be more
secular they then some for some reason
you could sort of see it with covet they
were all about fear basically overnight
and now that's sort of permeated through
everything yeah there's just no question
about this this is the other thing
that's always at the core of everything
you know we we have been taught to think
about history without God in it so you
know we'll say God is dead you know and
then and that's a perfectly Fair
statement to make comparing the Middle
Ages to the 19th century but you have to
understand that what that means is he's
dead in our hearts he's dead our
churches are are failing us it doesn't
mean he's actually dead and so we have
to start thinking about what it is we're
doing here as human beings because if
what we're doing here is trying to live
as long as we can before we die uh then
when you know Jake Tapper comes on CNN
and says no you must be afraid you must
be fearful uh then yeah we should be
fearful because as as Andrew Cuomo uh
said what's what could be worse than
that death but when we start to say no
we're actually part of a greater
spiritual journey and sometimes just
like the guys who you know invaded
Normandy beach sometimes we have to face
death and even accept that as part of
that Journey then then you have a very
different way of looking at things you
know I'm I'm fortunate that I'm like a
you know a chattering guy like you I'm a
writer and all that stuff I don't often
have to dodge bullets uh or run onto a
beach being sprayed by machine guns but
I wouldn't I wouldn't for one second
restrain what I say because people might
cancel me I know that because I've done
it I've been kicked out of Hollywood
basically yeah uh and and you know I I
would never ever do that not because I'm
not you know it's not because I'm brave
it's because in God I'm fearless uh as
long as I'm in God as long as I'm
centered in God I know that I just have
to do what's right and I will I will be
okay in the long run even if that long
run is eternal and not within my
lifetime so we we've yes when you lose
that when you lose that hook and to
something bigger than yourself
everything becomes fear how can it be
anything else because we're all just
these fragile little people who are here
today and gone tomorrow and if we're not
part of something Eternal what's the
point of ever putting your head over the
edge of the trench it's so interesting
because when people come up to me like
at the store or something and they'll be
Dave it's so you're so brave you're
saying all the things that I want to say
and I always have two thoughts at the
exact same time one is well hey I'm not
being shot at I'm not I'm not in war so
I'm not brave to that extent that it's
just not a real comparison and B I don't
know that it's bravery that causes me to
say the things that I believe sometimes
I think it's just I'm like I'm nuts I
guess maybe I'm just kind of nuts
like I don't know everyone seems to be
afraid of this thing yet I seem to be
one of the people doing it like I don't
know maybe I'm crazy I don't know if
that makes you Brave I I always remind
myself that we do have an extra layer of
protection because we speak for a living
so we're protected by the first
amendment in ways that a guy who works
in the clothing industry or the car
industry is not protected in the same
way and they can say to him you didn't
sign the HR papers saying that you know
a man can become a woman right right
you're fired so so we we're a little bit
uh more protected but yes I also think
that that is what the times require so
it's People Like Us who uh who remain
because that's what the time required if
you're not if you if you're not able to
do that you're not going to be doing
what we're doing what do you think of
reformation for the Democrats your old
friends that you can talk to what would
it look like like what do you think
could happen over there that would
reverse the insanity right like to me
right now there's a decent fight on the
right there's like okay are we going to
go the Trump route are we going to go
the DeSantis route I think there's good
Arguments for both either they're going
to have to figure it out on the DL or
the or it's going to happen out publicly
and I think either one probably is fine
but on the left it's hard to figure out
like what are you people going to do
with this this monster that is there
yeah I see I think that the the delusion
that the left is living under the nice
people on the left and there are many
many of them many good people on the
left the delusion is that yes the people
who are butchering children may have
gone too far but there is a version of
this where that doesn't happen right and
and that's not true yeah I mean it's all
one it's all one thing and and so uh
look there is there is something called
liberalism which may be uh supports more
of a welfare state for instance than I
would support I would think I would like
to see more things done by private
Charities I would like to see the Great
Society dismantled I think it's been a
disaster I think that all of the stuff
that people are attributing to the
police which have not who have nothing
to do with it uh really can be
attributed to the Great Society which
destroyed black families and made black
people dependent and basically
um funded all kinds of bad behaviors
that have destroyed black communities uh
you know I'd like to see all of that go
away but I can imagine a liberalism
that's sort of like Frederick Friedrich
says you know we need a little bit of a
I have a um welfare state so people
won't be afraid to take chances and take
risks and all that stuff uh if you can
create recreate that liberalism that was
the liberalism that I grew up with
um yeah then you'll have sanity on the
left again but either they're going to
follow these people
to the point where their children are
taken away from them because they won't
let them wear a dress or they because
they won't cut a
healthy girl's breasts off
um you're either going to follow those
people or you're going to have to side
with us if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell